hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong the show where
we take movies and particularly today
the entire body of work of a particular
artiste and debate whether rotten
tomatoes is wrong according to the
beloved tomato meter big big news
everyone i've been flying solo for a
while now and i got to do great films
like return of the jedi and top gun but
now she's back my wonderful co-host
jacqueline coley
the queen has returned how are you i'm
doing great man i really appreciate it
glad to be back much needed break but
glad to be back you get some good r and
r what was the highlight of it
the highlight of it was you can say a
video game a video game no i did do
stuff while i was off but i'm just
trying to think about the highlight of
what it was the highlight of it was
honestly
waking up and playing uh don't starve
because i did that a lot and i became
obsessed with that game absolutely
obsessed i like it uh so jacqueline as
as you all know is not only a co-host of
this show she covers movies she goes to
film festival she's on the award circuit
me i'm a full-time comedian and
apparently a part-time video game
salesman according to twitter uh my
twitter got hacked everyone so don't try
to buy a ps5 from me i'm not selling
them and i've had so many people text me
hey do you still have any ps5s left how
dumb are my friends i need to upgrade
because a lot of my friends still think
that i'm going to be selling them a ps5
for five bucks
wait a minute selling anybody a ps if i
was gonna sell a video game system it
would be a sega genesis out of my trunk
not a ps5 on twitter one of the comedian
friends that i have who did not text me
yesterday because a he's super busy
co-hosting shows like boards in the hood
which he also co-created when he's not
doing his many jobs at night which range
from professional wrestling to
professional stand-up comedy
jay washington did not text me yesterday
and jay this is why you and i are so
tight sometimes less is more particular
in a situation when your dear friend
mark gets hacked how are you i'm well i
also was like yo
is mark on hard times that he's selling
ps5s they say you know what it's not my
cross to bear not my struggle i'ma let
this man just like hey man i'm doing it
for charity i was like nope i'ma let
this sort itself out and then it did
because all of a sudden i saw marcus
hacked and i was like sounds about right
sounds good
yeah as if as if us comedians weren't
under a literal attack enough this week
jay now we got to deal with our twitter
getting hacked so
we all are blessed to have 99 000
followers like you sir so yeah well this
person that we're talking about today
has i think the last instagram tally was
like 30 or 35 million following
and that would be the one the only
dwayne the rock johnson so we've done
this before a few different times and
it's always a hoot we did we covered
nicholas cage recently and all of his
great films so we're going to do that
with dwayne johnson because like there's
a lot of great movies there's a lot of
duds but there's also those movies that
sometimes we feel like the tomato meter
got wrong hence the name of the show
rotten tomatoes is wrong so by the
numbers here's dwayne the rock johnson's
average when it comes to films he's got
a 52 tomato meter average across all of
his movies 23 rotten films 13 fresh from
2001 to 2015 he only had four fresh
films so he's rebounded nicely recently
his audience score average is 63 so that
is fresh but when you talk about the
rock you talk about franchise and box
office viagra to date over 12 billion
dollars in receipts with a per movie
average of 353 million bucks that is a
lot i could buy twitter with that
actually i could at least buy some stock
and twitter with that money um jay
we're going to start with you here the
question that we always ask everyone is
you know because you're a returning
champion here what is your favorite
dwayne johnson movie and is rotten
tomatoes wrong about it i have two i'm
literally a toss up
one
is pain and gain
okay because you watch him go through a
ray of emotions and watch that man
barbecue a foot
i said what
while he was higher than that thing
like and he was doing it like it was
nothing
and then be cool
because of the way he played elliot it
was amazing it was like it was a whole
nother character on a whole nother level
and just the interactions with vince
vaughn and everything else the whole e
weezy you know it was just great
but i do think rotten tomatoes ronald
should have been rated a little bit
higher i believe those should have been
rated higher those are both rotten
movies who pick nice round numbers
because
currently sitting at 50 percent on the
tomato meter is your first film pain and
gain your other movie be cool very early
in the rock's acting career 30
according to tomatoes and so now let's
see what jacqueline coley's favorite
dwayne johnson movie is jacqueline i
have here in my notes that your answer
is baywatch why excuse me what
what
[Laughter]
it is
everyone
uh i do love that you wanted to throw me
a little curveball cause i was like uh
lucy no she lied to you
i was like i was like i was on vacation
and she just took whatever i sent her
and was like this sounds good no i'm
kidding uh no my favorite movie is
actually another early rock one uh it
actually is fresh to both an audience
and in critics but my love for it is
particular and that's the rundown so the
rundown is a movie that came out in 2003
this is like literally the beginning of
the dwayne rock johnson transferring
over from the wwe like he had done like
i think two maybe three movies before
then including like uh how did why did i
get married two which by the way that is
a great cameo that he has at the end of
that and then we never see him again but
he wasn't it uh but i love the rundown
because uh for folks that don't know my
dad worked in the movie industry and he
worked on that movie as a caterer slash
driver
and that movie was filmed in hawaii and
i got to go out there for three days so
that was actually the
one of the first movie sets i ever went
to and so that's why that particular
movie has like a personal
um place in my heart yeah and it's and
it's interesting because we're going to
talk about another cameo that might be
in the rundown that you and i are a big
fan of and so for me i look at like my
favorite dwayne johnson movies and
obviously you could put something like
moana way up there that's 95 of the
tomato meter it's not a big argument
about that i think fast five when he
really solidified himself as franchise
viagra but that movie's super fresh 77
i am going to go with the movie that i
think is criminally underrated and i
think that there was a lot of hubbub a
lot of talk about this movie and how
it's going to affect the industry as a
whole and that would be the netflix film
red notice at 36 percent
rod tomatoes are just wrong on this one
i had a ball watch in this movie and i
rewatched it again and i enjoyed the
hell out of it only 36 percent but the
audience score we got a man on fire
situation because the audience score is
92 percent and so i definitely start
with the audience more than i do the
tomato meter on this one and so we're
going to get into a deep dive talking
about all three of the four of these
movies but also some other fun dwayne
the rockstars and facts in there as well
before we do any of that we're now going
to turn it over to the great tim ryan
our expert review curation manager here
at rotten tomatoes he's gonna give us
some critic commentary spanning the
entirety of the rock's career tim take
it away
[Music]
he may be one of hollywood's most
popular and bankable stars but it's
something of a surprise to say that
determining the best reviewed dwayne
johnson movie is actually harder than it
looks
if you're going by tomato meter with a
large number of reviews then the winner
is moana in which he has the lead voice
performance it's certified fresh at 95
on the tomato meter if you're going with
a movie in which dwayne johnson appears
in the flesh that would be fighting with
my family which is certified fresh at 93
percent although in this one he's
playing himself next up is furious 7
which is certified fresh at 82 percent
but although he's a major part of the
franchise's success the furious films
are more ensemble pieces than single
star driven vehicles no pun intended
therefore if you are going by a film in
which dwayne johnson is the lead and
playing a fictional character in a
live-action film then the winner is
jumanji welcome to the jungle which is
certified fresh at 76
on the other side of the coin the worst
reviewed dwayne johnson film is baywatch
which is at 17
so what do the critics have to say in a
fresh review for jumanji welcome to the
jungle alex flood of nme wrote we defy
you not to laugh every time the rock
let's loose his eyebrow-tastic signature
look robin williams would have been
proud however in a rotten review for
baywatch anthony lane of the new yorker
wrote thank heaven for dwayne johnson
whose foot wide smile will not be
switched off and who saves the life of
the movie
whether it deserves to be saved is
another matter so that's a brief
overview of the career of dwayne johnson
let's take it back to jacqueline and
mark who in the world of podcasting are
the people's champions back to you folks
oh well i certainly smell that
compliment thank you tim that means a
lot to us and now we are gonna
transition right into
a movie talk
[Music]
i have some particular work cut out for
jay because jay's gonna have to sell me
on why pain and gain is uh one of his
favorite rock movies because
there is going to be some debate about
that i feel like we're all going to
agree on the rundown and i might have to
play some defense myself when i lobby
for and not against red notice but
before any of that jay the first time
the rock came on your radar i imagine it
was during his wrestling days
when he makes the transition from
wrestling onto the big screen did you
see
any of this coming did you foresee a
career where he would eventually one day
be the biggest not just action star but
the biggest star on the planet and on
hollywood screens
i didn't think he would ever be this big
i mean you see the transition hulk hogan
had made and it was a big transition
right
but it wasn't massive you've seen other
wrestlers go into acting and you're like
okay cool they have some star power
i don't think anybody could have
predicted that dwayne johnson would
break the illuminati code take the new
world order over and become the biggest
box office star in history i don't think
anybody can predict anybody that says
they could have predicted that is pretty
much a lie straight up let's just be
honest yeah i mean you can prognosticate
future success for someone jacqueline
but jay brings up hulk hogan you think
about andre the giant when wrestlers
were in film back in the day it was more
or less just playing a version of
themselves and i've heard that criticism
lobbied before against the rock where he
always just kind of shows up and he's
the rock do you still buy into that or
do you think that he's firmly
established himself as somebody who has
a range when it comes to acting i mean i
don't know if he's established himself
as someone that has a range he has a
range within his sandbox i'll put it to
you that way can he give you
a comedic moment and then go kick
somebody in the face sure can he you
know really give you i would say
very powerful i'm coming to
get this person thriller vibe sure
am i gonna be seeing him in a my left
foot type situation not too much so
like that's just the way i would put it
like everything is within his sandbox
but yeah within that sandbox that
sandbox has expanded whether it's i
would definitely say
early rock was straight action with
dabbles of comedy and that's the reason
why i love the rundown is because i
think that really showed his comedic
chops outside of the wwe when you get to
something like jumanji he's perfected it
and when you look at those two films you
see the difference one is action with
comedy sprinkled in in a very sort of
bruce willis
sly sort of way and then by the time you
get to something like jumanji i mean the
com the comedy of what he's doing
playing somebody like alex wolf
mentally and looking like him that's him
stretching to me yeah jay i feel like he
has a lot more range than people give
him credit for especially now and and
one of those movies even though i'm not
a fan of it i think pain and gain did
that because he had to be both dramatic
and comedic at the same time and
one of the earlier i guess it was a mid
mid you know career rock
film was called snitch and that wasn't
just a straight up action movie there
was certainly action in it but he had
some like real dramatic scenes and now
like jacqueline intimated there's a lot
of laughs that dwayne johnson's capable
of getting on a level with like you know
another shredded hero that we think just
about action movies with but chris
hemsworth can be very funny too so let's
get to pain and gain here let's get into
this movie why is this movie so
criminally and i mean that with the pun
intended underrated for you
not to mention just let's duane johnson
decide you got mark wahlberg just being
mark wahlberg you got
you
got anthony mackey playing a former
steroid user who's gone impotent and
he's upset about it like it's somebody
else's fault
but him is what dwayne johnson as paul
doyle
plays a convict who tries to turn to
christ while still dealing with his drug
addiction at the same time he's
conflicted on so many different levels
and throughout all the stuff that mark
wahlberg takes him through into the
point where he kills the guy and he ends
up cooking his foot and all that gets
shot running from the police to go back
to church later you're like wait it's
it's so much he does in just this movie
and so on top of everything else like
when you have when he's cooking the foot
on the grill when the super has to come
up and says remember this is a true
story
it really happened that's why this i
this is a movie i can revisit i'm like i
just need to watch something that just
can't be real but you're like oh it's
real
i think the true story element of it
though jacqueline is kind of what threw
me off because i felt like michael bay
never he was looking for a tone wait and
he never really got missile lock on what
he was going for because there are these
like crazy
comedic segments but then there's also
like an underlying touch of sadness
because we know the that this is a true
story we know that real people were
murdered and so just the way it has such
a glee telling the story i don't know it
it felt like it was a little uneven for
me how did you see it oh definitely i
think that was michael bay trying to
because what was painting game what year
was that
was released in movie theaters oh yes
the great year 2013 2013. i think that
was him trying to go into his uh kiss
kiss bang bang era
you know what i mean like i really do i
i i remember kiss kiss bang bang was
early 2000s like somewhere between like
2003 2004 obviously before iron man so
it had to be early and i feel this was
part of that i think it was him saying
like it seems like these guys that
confuse comedy into
action or having a better go of it yeah
it was it's this tragedy so i guess jay
the question is not because i know you
have a very big heart but like
it's it's it's a very tough thing it's a
very narrow window you're trying to
squeeze the story into when you're
talking about a real tragedy and you're
not making like a true crime documentary
about it you're you're actually making
what a lot of folks consider to be sort
of a weird buddy cop action comedy
through a fun house mirror
right and then it's also michael bay so
there has to be explosions somewhere
and that term and that and that shot
that shows that just circling around
shot it has to be there but in the midst
of all that like i said you get a story
of somebody trying to make it
another guy trying to get by on his life
and another guy trying to change his
life and so when you see all those
different elements play together
that's for me what resonates the most
when you see them is sort of have to
team up or then then they're at odds and
so i guess they're right first
constantly bounces back and forth
they're together then they're apart they
can agree then they disagree they fight
they argue the arguments for me anyway
are the highway to the movie like just
watching him and and wahlberg and and
sometimes mackie in there too just sort
of like trade barbs and just watch them
fall in and out of friendship i think
that's the highlight of the movie for me
and and i just have to remove myself
from knowing i guess
what ultimately went down between these
characters real with the part when after
mark wahlberg royd rages out and kills
the guy with the weight and then he
literally looks over says i got to get a
pump in i got to get a pump in and you
got dwayne johnson like yeah yeah dude
that do that do that and then mark
warwick was like so what are we gonna do
he's like ain't no we did this you
killed him like ain't no we this is you
and you got mark robert like wait what
huh like yeah this is you like you did
that i'm not going back to jail for you
on this like that's those beautiful
things you get out of that movie i gotta
get a pump
yeah take a moment
[Music]
listen danny i know what it's like to
think you killed somebody
and it hurts
i mean you got jesus and the devil
swirled that's it get it jesus devil
swirling all up in your head i was lucky
because my god lived
so you must really feel like
just because i i feel like i have to ask
you this just because you are around
wrestling and you're constantly working
out in gyms getting getting your pump on
have you ever seen somebody that you
know like a friend and then they're a
different person because of roid rage i
agree yes yes i'll just say yes i was
gonna start david dave cause i was like
i'm gonna do this oh we'll do this i
mean i've seen so many people in the pro
wrestling industry that i've watched go
from uh people your size mark which is a
nice size so all of a sudden people
dwayne johnson's size in six weeks i was
like bro your genetics ain't that good
like you're saying the lord have not
blessed your dna like that why do you
think this is a thing and you see it and
you see the way the effects it has on
them you see the roid rage all right
yeah that happened you see the road rage
you see the anger you see the aggression
and all those things so i've been around
it
jacqueline i i feel like 50
i'm going to say that's fair for pain
again do you have a strong feeling on
this tomato meter score not really again
it's like with a michael bay movie
outside of like a handful of them um
i can't really think of any of them that
i'm like oh i would feel very upset if i
never ever got to see this again and
this was definitely not that it for me
this movie was one of those movies where
the only thing i remember about it and
no offense jay i love you but a lot of
dudes with tribal tattoos in the mid
210s
have been making their entire
personality about that movie and that's
literally the only taste i have in my
mouth about it ten years later and i'm
not saying anything against you jay okay
because i didn't think that move my life
will say nope i'll play but do you have
a tribal tattoo
can we go to the next part of this
question
see what had happened was
i was uh i mean i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say anything but i'm like i stand
by my my assertion that's all i will say
you know you know what i don't want you
know what i like the way this
conversation is right now it's okay it's
okay i didn't mean to do this i didn't
mean to do this it's only because we're
friends i would never do this to a first
time guest i know some people are like
is she really going this hard for him
it's only because i know jay i also know
he has that tattoo and number three like
legitimately mark knows what i'm talking
about this was a bro movie painting
it was it was a very broad movie
it's a very bro it's a very dude dude
bro bruh bro and the movie i like is a
very bro movie the rob's filmography
let's be real is very broly so you know
i'm not in any way like my movie was
that version if you know it was like the
hipster bro version because the rundown
wasn't a huge huge movie but if you saw
it you would definitely make it your
personality yeah the difference between
the rundown of pain and gain for me is
that like people people looked at pain
and gain and based their lives on trying
to be those characters in the same way
that they did wall street when it came
out in the 80s where it's like oh they
didn't really realize that gordon gekko
is the bad guy in the movie they're like
i just want to look like that and i
think some of the same with the tribal
tattoos or just constantly being in a
gym and doing roids and bad things
outside of the gym as well i think the
pain and gain did inspire some of that
but we can't always pin all that on a
movie with the rundown it just really
made me want to have fun with the rock
and sean william scott and so jacqueline
the the four is now yours to defend your
movie even though it is fresh you think
it should be higher oh absolutely i
think it should be higher and you really
kind of talked about it and it is the
chemistry between dewayne the rock
johnson and sean william scott and and
the bro ness of sean william scott is
why this thing worked that movie was
perfect for its time frame you guys you
have to remember this was the american
pie era this was the euro trip era and
for a movie like that it was still a
film
where i felt that it tried a little bit
like it showed sean william scott for
the privileged little crap that he is
you know it also i think gave dwayne the
rock johnson a chance for him to really
show himself for what he wanted to be to
be a legitimate not just like a throw
you in the movie action star but a
legitimate i look at somebody like
florian montanu from creed and then also
from shanghi right now that could have
been all the way in the rock johnson was
and he made a conscious effort to turn
himself into a movie star and but where
he was in the rundown was that point and
this was the movie that really in my
opinion
any dwayne the rock johnson movie that
you're looking at later and you're
saying this guy's a star that was the
movie that showed you exactly what he
could do and all of the talents that he
was cultivating to where again when you
get to a movie like jumanji which was a
huge hit it's one of its highest rated
movies
you see all like the seeds of it there
and the passing of the torch of it there
and it's really funny and it's shot in
hawaii and it looks good and peter berg
is kind of a madman and i would say that
he also is somebody who the fun that he
has on his sets i think translates
on screen yeah peter berg is another guy
jay who's like michael bay and that you
you you definitely know what tone
they're going for and and he sets out to
make a very specific kind of movie with
the rundown i love the cameo at the
beginning from arnold schwarzenegger
because
uh
there's a scuffle going in going at a
nightclub and as schwarzenegger is
walking out
dwayne is walking in and they just kind
of bump shoulders and schwarzenegger
looks at him he says good luck in there
and that is sort of schwarzenegger
passing through
as he goes into his gubernatorial career
saying hey in there isn't just some
nightclub where brawl broke out in there
is hollywood in there is the competition
for the next great action star so as
arnold is walking off into the sunset
from his glory days that may never be
topped by another action actor the rock
is going in there and so jay i kind of
look at the rundown as the rocks last
season in the minor leagues where he's
proving himself and he's just putting up
insane aaa numbers and you're like this
guy's ready for the show again you have
that like you just said you have that
torch passing you have that handoff from
the action star and arnold
schwarzenegger the muscle guy in
schwarzenegger yes you had stallone
try to mimic that in a sense
but it never reached that same level of
what schwarzenegger was and so this
passing you get like jacqueline said you
get this ella it's not a broly movie
it's a level it's it's different type of
theme movie it's not this bro movie
everything else becomes but it's
something different and then it's like
okay this dude is real this dude is
really in movies now
this is no longer
we were still calling him the rock for a
little bit but it's like this is dwayne
johnson now yeah now we're seeing dwayne
johnson that's what we got out of that i
will say that too i want to add to this
one on that one um the mark hoffmeyer
gave us the great story of how that
cameo came to be and it was while arnold
was governor he was actually having a
lunch at the universal lot which is just
minutes away from the neighborhood where
we all live and like he was just on set
one day and the president of universal
at the time was having lunch with him
he's like hey we're filming this movie
with the rock
uh you want to come take a look at it uh
it was the i would say the interiors
obviously in like nightclub scene they
were filming on the lot they filmed the
rest of the movie in uh hawaii but yeah
they did the movie and and arnold was
like yeah if you can do it today give me
an hair and makeup and let me do it they
shot it that afternoon and i just think
that's so cool that you you could move
that quickly and the cameo was so
perfect and the timing of it was so
perfect because you could only get
arnold schwarzenegger to do that cameo
like that while he was governor
as a favor and it was just one of those
days where the the hollywood gods smiled
upon the movie the rundown i put that
cameo on a par with like
this is going to be a deep cut david
letterman and cabin boy anybody my god
david letterman cabin boy
that's chris elliott right yep wow i
haven't thought that you know what was
weird that was in the snl comedy movie
heyday which we don't get anymore at all
but it was like it was like cabin boy it
was like uh that they were after their
snl movie so it's like the poly shore
era jury duty uh you know what i mean
like like but after the snl movie it
seemed like all of them did these like
one-off comedies that weren't
necessarily snl characters but they had
solidified themselves as so i married
max murderer thank you exactly like that
even to a certain extent jim carrey and
once bitten that was the living color
version of that for him you know what i
mean yeah and i just it's so interesting
now to think about those movies because
we don't have those i mean i guess king
of staten island was the closest we've
gotten to that recently right pop star
pop star but that wasn't that was it
wasn't snl directly yeah you're right
yeah it was very close
youtube has killed that because now they
have all these little snl skits all the
time the idea of like extending it for a
movie now they just want more of less
well i'll tell you what you can't do on
youtube you can't put out a movie
like red notice because that could only
be a monster netflix production
ryan reynolds and of course dwayne the
rock johnson directed by ross and
marshall thurber who has been in the gym
and him and his wife took like this this
fitness challenge and they're both just
like they look like fitness models now
when they're not working on big-time
movies i think the red note is when it
was announced and it came out and it was
and it came direct to netflix like that
was always the idea i think it gave a
lot of people pause as to where the
industry is going because they're like
wait we can put the biggest blockbusters
with the biggest movie stars direct to
netflix what's going to happen to movie
theaters and i feel like that was the
movie that just caused a big ripple it
was like a
the time and space continuum of what
hollywood has been forever sort of felt
a
seismic shift the tectonic plates moved
a little bit for hollywood but just the
movie itself i really enjoyed the pace
of it the comedy of it i think ryan
reynolds might steal the whole movie but
they all shine individually as they
range from thieves to
fbi uh profilers who are catching
thieves and they're all looking for
these mysterious eggs that have ancient
egyptian war attached to them and
there's three eggs and we're running
around looking for him and i have no
idea why the movie's as low as 36
because to me it feels every bit as fun
as a national treasure movie it's not to
the level of indiana jones but what is
and it also felt like the the action and
the over-the-topness of it felt like
anything that you would see in fast five
or fast six or fast seven and the
critics seem to appreciate those for
whatever reason but not red notice am i
way off base here jay is red notice a
terrible movie that i'm just i have
blinders on for some reason i don't
think it's a terrible movie i enjoyed it
i will openly admit i enjoyed red notice
i also will say this look let me just be
honest gal gadot gal gadot how you
pronounce it pardon my love uh plays the
same person in every single movie
she's the same person if you talk about
certain people in every she was the
exact she she basically was princess
diana without her wonder woman gear on
at a point you know what i'm saying and
ryan reynolds is going to be ryan
reynolds you could say that for ryan
reynolds too i was going to say that
yeah you just know but you know that's
what you're going to get with right
it's never an expectation of anything
else with ryan reynolds i think that's
the thing with gal you know you want to
see a different range of a character you
just said it with a dwayne johnson with
a ryan reynolds we come to understand
this is going to be ryan just being ryan
just with a character name like that's
what this is but then red notice it it
moved a lot there were a lot of pieces i
was like okay so what's really going on
and then when you find out the whole
double and triple cross you're like wait
what so i like i don't i definitely
liked it don't get me wrong so i don't
want to bite thinking he didn't like the
movie i did i did a lot of twists and
turns and jacquard as you know because
we've seen a lot of movies together i am
an absolute idiot when it comes to
seeing a pot twist coming i never see
anything i never find out who the killer
is until five minutes after it's been
revealed but i really liked all of the
twists and turns this movie takes you
through and i thought the action was fun
um i have my little qualms about how
we're basically all three of us are are
killing police officers around the world
and we don't really feel bad about it
even though we were working with them
but you know if you have the problem
with that in movies then you're gonna
you're gonna have a problem with a lot
of movies so how does jacqueline coley
feel about my
one of my favorite dwayne the rock
johnson movie spread notice um okay so
this is what i would tell you
i haven't seen it
right you didn't even want to watch it
she started this beautiful preamble well
let's
and by the way though i want to be very
clear it came out during award season
you know that i wasn't going to see that
mark i saw i knew that you were
selecting that because you told me on
the phone but i literally said to you i
was like i'm not doing that and i didn't
know at least even in the heat of awards
season you at least can acknowledge that
when the movie dropped people were like
is this the way that we're going to be
watching movies here too for our
theaters like it was it was a weird it
was a weird jump to make for me anyway
well this is what's weird for me about
red notice because that's what i was
just about to say is i'm not going to
disagree but i didn't see it but what is
interesting about red notice
is the amount of coverage and the life
cycle of the coverage around what that
movie meant not just to dwayne the rock
johnson but to netflix that is correct
and what's so interesting now if we look
at the grand scheme of things and i'm
not whatever you could honestly say red
notice was netflix's biggest and best
effort they got literally three of the
biggest movie stars on the planet
deadpool black adam and wonder woman
come on that is huge
and green lantern and you know the
spider king and whatever else gal gadot
has played
and they still
i honestly think in a year from now
people won't remember they did a movie
together the disposability of how big
that movie is is the thing that scares
me considering how many stars are in it
yeah it did feel very disposable it you
know jay it almost felt like a more
i don't know run down version uh not to
borrow jacqueline's movie of an ocean's
eleven type film where let's just get a
bunch of famous people and let's have a
heist and let's have a lot of laughs on
set and see if that translates over and
i think it did translate over but but
like you said it's pretty much
gao and ryan and duane being themselves
but ryan reynolds is
is playing deadpool in this he's playing
wade wilson but
he really had fun with it but like
jacqueline just said the it was that is
this what movies is okay because we were
in we're still we're we're still we were
in the heat still a covet people were
needing things to do theaters weren't
really a big thing yet again you know
people were still like other open but i
don't know if i want to go but this is
on netflix so let's do it you already
had other movies like extraction six
underground the old guard monies movies
that netflix is putting money in right
already but it didn't hit the reach it
hit until it did red notice and they
were like wait netflix is making
marvel studios level money movies
and the problem is people like well how
will they recoup this what is going to
be the metrics to gauge the software
because of course with movies and
theaters well what's the domestic what's
the worldwide what's the international
growth all these things you just like
how many streams do they get that's
literally it and we don't know it that's
which is numbers
you have to be in the skulls to get the
netflix numbers and
wait no no i'm not gonna pass by that
joshua jackson late 90s full no sir
i'm feeling it
i'm feeling dawson's creek star movies i
look it when your twitter gets hacked
you're forced to think a new way a paul
walker movie too man you were keeping it
like fast the furious like all in there
synergy baby that's what i i just want
consistency from from everything and
that includes our good friend the tomato
meter is it if you're just gonna gush
and make every fast and furious movie
fresh my question is what are those
movies doing that red notice didn't do
because all the fast and furious is
maybe with the exception of five they
all feel like the same long movie to me
and red notice at least by the end of it
it's trying to set itself up to be a
franchise like that i i don't know what
jay would say but i would just say like
red notice was a movie made by committee
in the middle of a pandemic that got
shut down twice so i don't know if
that's the same
as like
at the end of it look at the end of the
movie you can tell it was shot they was
like hey everybody socially distanced
for real
you know what i mean like i don't think
they just got happy to get to the finish
line of that one because any movie that
big those schedules are two years out
you know what i mean like there's too
many things going on and so any delay
for any reasons is really hard to
maintain that you keep everyone there's
so many instances of movies where you
know sterling k brown drops out of the
heart of they fall because they had to
move the date you know what i mean so i
actually think that
yeah i don't know because you look at a
film that would be under the similar
setting as something like red notice and
you're like yeah the reason why they do
better is because they're in theaters
and they can inventize them they can
become part of the landscape that can
build you up to a billion dollar
franchise and netflix movies just don't
have that formula
i feel like yeah i mean red notice was a
leap forward as far as netflix doing
that stuff but according to their their
numbers or their stock or whatever and
netflix is has been in the red for you
know ever since they stopped mailing out
dvds and so somehow they keep finding
money to make more of these projects and
the cycle continues but when we look at
these three movies let's expand it to
something like jay's other selection be
cool because that was very early on
in dwayne johnson's career and it acted
as a very loose sequel to get shorty or
in the same vibe of it so jay why is be
cool so underappreciated by everyone i
remember
i got introduced to this movie because
of him being on punk because of the
ashton kutcher stunt where he thought he
burnt up the uh traditional guard form
because he was using it for the scene
i remember that and i was like let me
see this movie and so watching it
automatically you get john travolta uma
thurman
harvey cocktail you got all the normal
people in certain big movies but then
you got dwayne johnson as a giant
bodyguard that you find out is gay
and it's like again that's a different
step for him to play and to lean not not
to go over the top you know flamboyant
games just like this is who i am and i
want to be in movies and things like
that i'm trying to find my way in
and to have his best friend and vince
vaughn who backstabs them
only to
end up getting redeemed and getting the
chance to be on a billboard with nicole
kidman
and dancing at the vmas with christina
million like
you can't it's look be cool is a giant
music video that you're waiting to have
the video happen like it's a long
preamble
to a music video and then you're like oh
there's more to the video okay cool
that's what would be cool is that's why
i like it i don't care what nobody's
saying man
yeah jacqueline that was a theater
experience for me because a bunch of my
friends like jay are huge wrestling
hawks and so they wanted to go see the
rock and i knew that stephen tywer the
lead singer of aerosmith was in the
movie and i think that we all enjoyed
the first get shorty and so we're like
yeah okay we'll all go see this movie
you have any strong feelings on be cool
one way or the other yeah i really loved
get shorty i really love ellard fillmore
and they'd amount stuff about that movie
early that made me be like this is not
the one for me
just because uh
uh you know what i mean like
yeah it's just yeah it was not it's not
the movie for me because like look like
rum you know rum punch is one of my
all-time favorite movies that's the one
that became jackie brown and
you know i really love get shorty and
i've read a lot of his books and i knew
that when i was like i just i love lucky
palma i loved all of his books it'd be
like if i heard somebody was adopting
adopting a jackie collins book and i
heard something about it that i didn't
like i'd be like i'm not going to watch
this so i know i saw be cool but i
wasn't about it was that was that uma 2
in that one or no yes it is yeah that's
uma yeah i was not about it in fact i
think she was the part i enjoyed the
most about that movie the best part
about either one of those movies get
shorty or be cool though is danny devito
being a giant movie star who's playing
napoleon and it's gonna be like the
biggest movie that's pretty pretty
fantastic when they when you see the
billboard for napoleon it's one of my
favorite parts one of my favorite
aspects of get shorty so as we look at
the the entire filmography here does
anything else stand out as far as like
really being i guess egregiously wrong
because the rest of his tomato meter
scores look pretty
pretty accurate like the other guys
where he has an extended cameo i'd call
it in is 78 that movie's hilarious and
he's a big reason why in the first act
fast five seventy-seven percent the
jumanjis are both fresh and then you get
to the the middling movies like snitch
like i said wasn't great but it was a
new step for him it's almost fresh at 57
get smart had a lot of laughs but not a
great film 51 like i'm i'm pretty cool
with all of these y'all have any other
discrepancies that you're like wait why
why is nobody
picketing why is nobody protesting this
i always want to know what my my my
theory my guideline my benchmark for
dwayne johnson's movies is what is the
rock gonna fight next and what i mean by
that he's fought gangs in gridiron gang
he fought an earthquake in san andreas
he fought a giant alligator and a flying
wolf in rampage he fought with families
and fight with my family you know what
i'm saying he fought with with moana and
moa like what is he gonna fight with
next he fights with kevin hart in every
movie so it's like what is the rock
gonna fight with next that's for me
the man fought an earthquake he fought
also skyscraper
the man fought a burning building with
one leg just one leg
he did
he did a leap that they had to do on
mythbusters this show physically it
could never happen the jump he does off
the crank they said there's no way he
could have made that with two legs
he holds a bridge up y'all he holds a
bridge up so neff campbell can walk
across it okay
what else is this man gonna do
that that jay actually had to sit down
and watch mythbusters because like there
was still a kernel of hope that he could
make that jump at some point and jay's
like i'm not i'm gonna let mythbusters
have the final word on this because i
think it could happen they did the john
madden telestrate it was like if you see
this curve right here and this 45 degree
angle he'd have never made it
yeah you forgot the the biggest feat of
the rock's uh career though jay is uh he
also defeated marines on mars when he
went rogue in the classic doom don't do
that
like doom never happened because that's
what everybody was like video game
movies are dead once he did doom
he played sarge in that beloved great
memes though great memes from that movie
great memes from doom yes
so my final question my my last thought
here uh as we close up the movie talk
portion of the episode what do you want
to see
dwayne johnson do
next what's the next movie start with
you jacqueline is it is it a sequel to
something we've already gotten is it
just a different genre for him where do
you want to see the rock go if you're
going to the movie theater and you're
walking in to see a new dwayne johnson
movie what do you want it to look like
i mean i want to see him work with more
female writers and script writers
honestly like doreen the walk johnson
has a great opportunity he's shown his
chemistry with emily blunt and it looks
like they're doing another movie with
her soon i think maybe we'll see but i
think that's where he needs to expand
because if he's really going to keep
himself carried
this is what i see happening to him he's
got to make a turn now otherwise it's
going to be mark wahlberg which is that
mark wahlberg still wants to do action
movies but mark wahlberg can't play
nathan drake anymore he has to play
nathan drake's older brother and i'm not
really sure that really makes
[Music]
mark wahlberg you know what i mean like
not even his older brother he has to
play like his like like drunken father
figure i don't know if that makes mark
wahlberg happy i think mark grauberg
likes being the scary
guy in the room kind of thing kind of
dude like he likes to play the bruce
willis world and so
i don't know i just don't know of how
many roles there are like that left in
modern uh movie making and so you've
gotta make the turn and so he's gotta
make a change is it rom-coms is it
looking to do more horror i don't know
like liam neeson made a turn and turned
himself into an action hero but he kept
doing it and now we see where he's at
yeah jay where does the rock go from
here it's an interesting point
jacqueline brings up is is working with
a different perspective behind the
camera because it can lead to more fruit
in a different genre
on screen yeah not not an action type
you know i want him to work with more
female directors for sure to be able to
tell look we need to see something
different and i don't give how big you
are put him let's see a real dramatic
role where he has to get really
emotional and the only fights he has to
have is with himself of something
mentally and emotionally we are always
going to expect to see him get physical
because it's just like well people want
to see dwayne johnson get physical
people want to see something different
the only fight he should have is an
emotional fight a mental fight and then
put it with a female director who can
pull that at him because again all of
the guys he's had directing him are like
all right so here's the scene where
you're going to punch this dude through
the wall all right and it's every
director has that at one point you're
gonna punch this dude he's gonna fly
back 57 feet we know logically it's not
supposed to happen but he's gonna be on
wire so don't worry so i want to see him
do that
all right this this sounds like your two
execs at his agency trying to expand his
i want to see him do action okay the guy
is a hulk of a human that my my short
answer to the question i asked i want to
see red notice two and three and four
that's what i want to see
the rock dude i don't want to see
self-serving the guy's not john cusack i
don't want to be sitting on a park bench
with diane lane talking about dogs i
want to see him
kissing in the rain because we
there's matthew mcconaughey
used rom-coms to get him from action
to get him used rom-coms to get him from
dramatic pretty boy
to
rom-coms to eventually get him into
dramatic this is the deal oscar glory
okay and then now oscar glory if you're
gonna make the shift you need baby steps
and in all honesty i think he thinks
he's gonna make the baby steps with the
mcu which he could robert downey jr
could definitely walk into a really
great slate
where is he going in with the mcu hold
on charlotte oh yeah the the dc movie
with uh with black adams
sorry i said dceu sorry dcu sorry dc
fans you can continue to come for me in
my dms uh no but with black adam just
knowing the story of how that character
is in the comics and definitely he deals
with that's not a very fluffy character
if you know a lot of the history around
that one i think that's his baby step
we'll see where he goes after that but i
also know he's doing a romantic comedy
with emily blunt so i think this idea
that i have in my head it seems that
the president and founder of five bucks
production companies also has that
thought like he knows like you only have
so many years as a glorified action star
and then you can either just keep being
an action star and staying in that genre
and probably not moving past that or you
could diversify i agree i mean you know
tom cruise he's still in action movies
but he also diversified his career
somewhat harrison ford same thing you
know and he's the only one that can
really do that because tom's cruise can
still make maverick but like think about
it when tom cruise makes a movie now
it's like
it's like imagine if it was fast and the
furious if vin diesel put as much effort
into it as ryan reynolds did with
deadpool like that's really what
tom does with with his films now like
he's involved from the minute they start
the script through the thing he's the
producer on all of them that's a totally
different gig than just being like
i'm gonna go do another action film yeah
i mean the rock could also retire right
now with tequila sales alone so i i
think he's doing just look terramon is
not the best tequila though it's okay
but it's it doesn't matter it's making
money minted
speaking of red notice both him and ryan
riddles made sure to have the perfect
product placement for both tara mana and
aviation gin in that movie they were in
the contracts i guarantee you before
either one of them signed on my gender
is gonna be
which by the way i will say this of the
two i will do a gen so i will have my
own liquor label i'll put it out on this
podcast so y'all can yell at me for
years but i am gonna have my own liquor
label and it is gonna be gin and it's
gonna be elderflower based because
that's all i like to drink i i saw
jacqueline have an elder flower cocktail
the other night and it looked delicious
i'm gonna hold out for gal gadot uh
sponsoring coors light all right that is
all for movie talk so now we're gonna
transition right into mailbag brian hit
that music
[Music]
wonder woman in coors light it's it's a
match made in heaven or maybe temaskira
uh our email today is from our esteemed
ketchup crew member cole you can be like
cole and email us anytime with movie
suggestions what you want to hear on an
upcoming episode of rotten tomatoes is
wrong just email us at rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com cole says hi gang
love the podcast i'm writing to
recommend the 2000's sci-fi horror film
pitch black i'm biased since i'm a
sci-fi fanatic but i think this stylized
creature feature is beautifully shot and
great fun and i think it's worthy of a
better score than its current 59
rotten i'd love to know what you all
think thanks cole yeah i have not seen
pitch black but i hear good things uh i
enjoyed uh riddick or the chronicles of
riddick whatever the most recent one was
and i feel like 59 there's so many good
movies spaceballs is the one i always
point to that are stuck at that 59
percent just
south of freshville so
facebook but we've not done pitch black
yet no we have not done pitch black yet
then i must have seen it for something
recently thank god we have fans like
cole who are writing us and telling us
what movies we need to cover and really
for me watch for the first time jay it's
always an honor when we get to spend
some time with you i imagine you're
heading to the gym later how many pieces
of the rocks gym attire collection do
you own not none because i don't they're
a little pricey yeah pricey because i
don't own any so if dwayne if you happen
to be listening to this and someone says
hey
at the rock you know mr j washington was
like yo he wants to wear some project
rock gear but he can't afford it because
he's just a single black father living
in a studio apartment trying to make it
you can send them all my way and the
rotten tomatoes folks will make sure
that i get it and the 3x size preferably
at the top because my shoulders and
chest is kind of broad and some shorts
you know i would like to smell what the
rock is cooking while i'm lifting thank
you very much
it looks great but you have to be at a
certain level of musculature to really
pull it off and i feel like i'm just now
knocking on the door that jay so when
you see me next time in person i just
want you to give me the once over and
and let me know if i'm ready to wear one
of those 80 dollar tank tops
now you see exactly why we say this
jacqueline 80 tank top
they look good though they really do
um i guarantee you they're not going to
look as good as the 80 would elsewhere
but that's me
you know what i'm going to do you know
it's a lot cheaper than 80 and it's
something that i'm going to be attending
and i think a lot of folks out there
listening should is right here in
southern california jay and winston
marshall boards in the hood are having a
live show at the bourbon room in
hollywood honoring juneteenth jay tell
us about that and all the other cool
stuff you got going on yes indeed
saturday june 18th at the bourbon room
in los angeles we're doing the first
ever live taping of blurred in the hood
like mark said me and winston a marshall
and we're doing a comedy show with
myself winston a marshall host mark
ellis is going to be gracing us with his
hilarious chuckles and we got a couple
other
special guests coming aboard uh you can
get the tickets at
shptickets.com shptickets.com
and you can catch blurrs in the hood
every tuesday and thursday 6 p.m pacific
9 pm eastern on twitch twitch.tv slash
blurgin the hood ble rds the letter
n-t-h-e-h-o-o-d
and for me the mad titan podcast
everywhere you get your podcast from i
talk about all the things in the marvel
and dc live action cinematic universes
is barbershop for nerd barbershop talk
for nerds come on in this convo and
y'all can find out where i'm at twitter
instagram tick tock and all that stuff
because i've been using tick tock
because i have to use tick tock now yeah
well it must be nice to uh must be nice
to be on twitter jay it must be nice it
sounds like a good time don't buy
playstations for me guys i'm not selling
them i mean look let's get out of here
so mark can hopefully see if he got his
twitter back because i i really feel him
going through it a bit
again hey i i played wii golf and took
naps yesterday i'm doing just fine we
need more hook videos from y'all
everybody listening out there if you
feel strongly about the stephen
spielberg movie from the early 90s some
consider it a classic i certainly don't
it's one of his few rotten movies on his
resume send in a quick vid email us at
rtswrong rottentomatoes.com with your
take on hook
until then that is jay washington that
is jack and coley i am mark ellis for
producing lucy our expert engineer brian
perez tim ryan and the whole gang here
at rotten tomatoes thanks for listening
until next time do not buy a video game
system from this guy we'll see you next
time on rotten tomatoes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you